just get in the middle Jesus Christ what
if I don't but oh my god
I'm trying try and get into the middle
why wouldn't it go I want to go into the
middle is stressing you out
what is your how's it going - bearpaw my
girlfriend is no way you know not this
time time I get to actually just be
myself
hey why did you pick him admit it we're
playing duck game I'm the black duck
I'm the white dog I'm the ugly duckling
that was racist
it was aa television head we made I
guess again as it's been 84 years with a
television finally we will settle that
one at a time you [ __ ] my girlfriend
brother ramiz again my brother
yeah on the benefit indeed sir
and now the widow of a crowned and the
kingdom taken the kingdom indeed I've
been eyeing it for many centuries I bet
I many things in the kingdom in heaven I
that Queens anxiety creams us we both
been eyeing the Queen's ass and the
winner so when a conversation there
seems a royal ass
Oh
you
good luck to you brother right good
life's best of luck to you too sir no I
are you ever prize we all walk seems to
me both a natural down 5-cc I know the
controls brother lucky for you neither
do I not quite sure which button is
shoot so we'll find out when you get
down house just give me one moment
brother it must be a fair fight don't
you agree I want some of that Queens ass
sister will be mine oh you got me again
brother a gift for you a mystery box
brother
ah man half convenient I want you holy
[ __ ] face ah don't you know my face is
made of paper bag - Tyler flammable ha
ha quite irresponsible
Melvin brother I'm good I'm sorry to
your room now brother oh wait you can't
color decent I'm still changing please
been role playing [ __ ] you
yo brother these are the ways mouth
moves I never want to speak with my own
voice of mouth again I jumped the Kibler
da-da-da-da-da
boys changed
it's no longer about nations ideologies
or anything like Wade duck you're solid
don't get in this Christ by everything
yeah that's amazing site you got down
there don't worry about it
Oh 360 news game [ __ ] okay get this gun
do an actual proper three-to-one draw
for that brother brother
we meet again one final harem on the
bottom of indeed brother the center back
to the center back to back just like old
times ten steps us all the ways Wow
wait let me just mix it were two three
three oh five six seven seven what's
going on I hear you moving out every
seven eight eight eight night how many
steps was it you said ten and draw no no
nice 1510 1011 1112 marks appear walls
it looks like I win brother there are
and run out the Royal Pavillion Swedish
cheating ways once again you win my
sanity's you always fall for it sweeter
the country of lies live like a little
lie little sweet lies which is like and
we fished them alpha system
I only play racing games it's alright
alright what happens it through those oh
if we lose you get to eat a burn
we should have said that
event event be a Buddhist or yes we Ben
and Ben's gonna grate down